what do you got going on here with these
problematic customers
rich how you doing brother what's up man
can you hear me okay yeah yeah
got a really big customer of mine
but my question is they're a top five
customer i'm in the industrial and
hydraulic hose fitting business
cincinnati ohio
when
in your estimation when they'll no
matter how much they're doing with you
when is it you're not worth it i mean
the demands on my time
60 to 80 hours a week but it's a 200 000
a year customer does it ever get to a
point where you say there's other
customers out there you guys gotta
one thing that you got to get good at is
firing people in your life and that
includes customers
there's a chapter in my book hire slow
fire fast
absolutely
i've read it on
same thing applies with customers man
you know if you have a shitty customer
and the juice is not worth the squeeze
um it's totally fine to tell them to get
lost um you know
you can deliver that message whatever
way you see fit
kinder or harsher but um why would you
invite terrible customers into your
business when
you should be spoiled for choice i mean
you should have more than just that
option
you know same thing applies with women
right i mean a lot of the stuff that
i've talked about applies to many
different facets of a man's life right
so
you got a customer that's not worth it
get it like would you tolerate an
abusive girlfriend generally speaking
most guys wouldn't right
right you get you know you get rid of
her get lost you know take your [ __ ]
locks are changing the front door
tomorrow get out of here take your cat
and go right
um
why would you tolerate a shitty customer
what if it's a
very small business with a very large
customer it's that you have a problem
then you have a problem because then
that customer has you wrapped around
their finger and they probably know it
so you need you need more customers or
you need to modify the business model so
that that so that that situation doesn't
happen there's got to be a way to do it
i mean you can take a look around your
industry to see what your competitors
are doing you can take a look at a
similar industry to see if they've
applied a similar solution to
what it is that um you're doing so you
know to share a story like the software
that i talked about earlier when we did
the pivot i got from a company in
florida
and um it was tailor-made to an american
um
program for debt relief that we had them
customize for us for the canadian
marketplace so i basically r d rip off
and duplicate took it from them applied
into my business with the modifications
and then boom you know we just kind of
ran with it so i mean there's any number
of things that you could possibly do to
solve this but again you know this is
more or less just a mindset thing like
how do you shift from
you know dealing with
one big fish in your tiny pond of a
business
that that is basically feeding you
to getting a whole bunch of fish maybe
slightly smaller fish or maybe bigger
fish you know but getting a bunch more
fish you know from a larger pond you
know growing the business
that's what we've done before we made
the decision to cut loose we've gone out
and garnered other business so it's not
so hurtful and you're exactly right
they know it and they think that they
have you um by the guts
for lack of better terms like well he
has to do it or else he'll go out of
business
right and i don't want to live my life
and my business like that
that yeah that's exactly the point i
mean
see a lot of people think that you know
being an entrepreneur is sexy and
glamorous but they're but i mean you can
put yourself in a situation where you
build a business that you hate because
you tolerate nonsense um there's a video
that i did on my channel i i was driving
up when i was going to do uh some
snowmobiling and i played a clip from
tony robbins who i'm not a big fan of
but he was absolutely right when he was
talking about raising your standards and
if you raise your standards in life with
the kind of customers that you want to
deal with
if you're an entrepreneur then you just
make sure that you do everything
possible to um hit those standards which
means that you're gonna have to change
you're gonna have to change the way that
you do things you're gonna have to
change the way that you mark you're
gonna change the way that you maybe
invoice your bill or run this structure
that you're running right now but that
change will get you towards where you
want to go if you're clear on where you
want to go
right yeah i don't want to be owned
by a customer what's the point i mean
like the whole point like i mean if
being an entrepreneur is so sexy and fun
then make it sexy and fun like don't be
somebody's [ __ ] and you're exactly
right i've had so many people come up to
me and look at my lifestyle my cars what
how i live and they're like oh that must
be great andy you own your own business
no it's not in a tiny company like ours
that does about a million a year and
gross
they own you you don't own that company
it owns you that's andy i'm glad you
mentioned that because that's one of the
points in the modules that i've got in
my in my course for this entrepreneurs
my mindset is about 98
point something like point seven percent
of businesses never do more than a
million dollars a year in sales so a lot
of people will go and create a business
they'll call themselves an entrepreneur
they'll say they're self-employed but
all they've really done is it is they've
built a business that now employs them
and they essentially have the same
uh compensation structure as if they
were working with a competitor that does
the same thing but now with more
liability because now somebody can sue
your business and now you have to deal
with that [ __ ] or they can pierce
the corporate shield and go right for
your property or do other things to you
so
you know you want to make sure that if
you're going to take on the risk of an
of an entrepreneur and get in that sort
of business that you don't put yourself
in a put yourself in an environment
where it's like i'm i'm getting paid a
hundred thousand dollars a year to do
something i could go and work for
somebody else at and check out the clock
at five o'clock and go home and be with
my family or do whatever but now i'm i'm
working all weekend in the evening i'm
not sleeping at night i've got this
legal issue that's going on my taxes are
behind there's all kinds of new problems
that you you know build so
in closing on this conversation andy
there's two ways that you can run a
business there's a guy called joe polish
i've mentioned it before there's a video
on my channel i talk about the
difference between an elf business and a
half business elf is easy lucrative and
fun it's an acronym half is hard
annoying lame and frustrating and by the
way you can apply this to relationships
with women too wouldn't you rather have
an elf relationship with a woman than a
half relationship with a woman
i do
i don't deal with [ __ ] anywhere
and then
in closing
this is exactly why um when i was beta i
was working 60 to 80 hours a week to
make this thing work and
the reason i got for cheating is you're
never around i never get to see you all
you do is work and i needed somebody to
pay attention to me right real real
sorry i'm trying to support you and
these two kids yeah and but this just
goes to show that it does not matter how
much money you make what kind of
lifestyle you provide if you are not
fulfilling her emotional needs she's
gone yeah well that's
in the beat sometimes it's just some
[ __ ] women too andy right
i know in the with the beast
you know to kind of like play play like
more on the positive side because a lot
of people you know complain a lot about
women and [ __ ] like there are women
there that will that will [ __ ] have
your back and stand by your side but i
mean you really have to spend some time
vetting them too right so it's like you
know you got to see how they deal with
all kinds of stuff but yeah like it can
go either way and you don't have any
control of that so again back to the
point if you're going to take on the
risk of running a business and being an
entrepreneur why not think bigger and
why not build something that is an easy
lucrative and fun business not hard
annoying lame and frustrating you've got
a half business right now pivot it into
a more fun business that serves you
got it thanks for everything rich i
really appreciate all you do for the
community yeah you're welcome man thanks
take care see you brother hey guys i
really hope that you enjoyed that short
clip if you did consider supporting the
creation of content by checking out my
supplement line pinned in the top
comment below of this video in the
comments there's a link to the unplugged
alpha dot com forward slash shop when
you click through you'll be able to land
over here and the entire lineup is
broken down by category that it performs
best in estrogen metabolism fat burning
your foundational essentials for health
immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model where regular shipments will be
sent over to you on a regular basis and
that gives you a little bit of a
discount and your supplement facts are
always broken down over here thanks for
watching i hope you guys have an awesome
day and again check out that link it's
pinned in the top comment below in this
video peace out
you